>> ♪ ♪
>> [CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> Sean: WHAT A WELCOME!
:
WELCOME TO "HANNITY" WITH A LIVE
AUDIENCE.
A STRANGE NEWSWEEK WITH
HYPOCRISY.
THE MOB AND MEDIA ARE IN
A PREDICTAMENT.
THEY SPENT SEVERAL MONTHS
DEMANDING THAT FORMER PRESIDENT
TRUMP BE INDICT ASKED THROWN IN
JAIL OVER CLAIMS HE MISHANDLED
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS.
WE HAVE A MAJOR DEVELOPMENT.
IT'S A PROBLEM FOR THE
HYPOCRITES.
THEIR BUDDY JOE BIDEN HAS BEEN
CAUGHT RED HANDED.
MISHANDLING TOP SECRET
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS THAT HE
APPARENTLY STOLE FROM THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION.
THE SENSITIVE MATERIAL WAS
STORED AT BIDEN'S UNSECURED
PRIVATE OFFICE AT THE U PENN
BIDEN CENTER, HIS HOME LIBRARY
AND NEXT TO HIS SPECIAL CORVETTE
IN HIS LOCKED GARBAGE EVEN
THOUGH WE HAVE PICTURES OF IT
WIDE OPEN.
THAT LITTLE CIRCLE IN THE "NEW
YORK POST" SHOWING THE PAPERS
JUST LAYING THERE.
BREAKING THIS WEEK THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES IS UNDER AN
INVESTIGATION.
ARE YOU HAPPY?
SPECIAL COUNSEL APPOINTED.
ONE SKETCHY DEPRAVED
SELF-SERVING INDIVIDUAL HAD EASY
ACCESS TO THOSE DOCUMENTS AND
THAT WAS THE PRESIDENT'S DEEPLY
TROUBLED AND FRANKLY CORRUPT SON
ZERO EXPERIENCE HUNTER.
HE LIVED AT THE DELAWARE MANSION
WHERE THE SECRET MATERIAL WAS
FOUND.
HE LISTED THE HOME AS HIS
BILLING ADDRESS FOR CREDIT CARDS
AND APPLE ACCOUNT.
ACCORDING TO THE "NEW YORK POST"
HE CLAIMED HE OWNED THE PROPERTY
ON A PRESENTAL APPLICATION.
WHEN HUNTER WAS IN THE THROES OF
HIS CRACK COCAINE ADDICTION.
HE USED PROSTITUTES -- AND HAD
HIS HAND IN BUSINESS SCHEMES
WITH CHINA AND RUSSIA WITH
BUSINESS PATTERSON WHO ARE --
PARTNERS WHO ARE NOW IN PRISON.
IS THIS A SAVE ENVIRONMENT FOR
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS?
I DON'T THINK SO.
DO YOU WANT SOMEBODY LIKE THAT
HAVING ACCESS TO AMERICA'S
SECRETS.
HUNTER COULD NOT KEEP TRACK OF
HIS OWN HANDGUN.
HE LOST IT.
OR HIS OWN LAPTOP.
HE PUT IT IN A REPAIR SHOP.
WE ARE SUPPOSED TO TRUST HIM
AROUND TOP SECRET MATERIAL.
HE IS 50 YEARS OLD.
WE ARE NOT TALKING ABOUT A CHILD
HERE.
WHEN HE WENT ON GOOD MORNING
AMERICA AND ASKED IF HE HAD ANY
EXPERIENCE WITH OIL AND GAS?
NOPE.
WHY DID THEY PAY YOU ALL OF THIS
MONEY?
I DON'T KNOW.
MAYBE BECAUSE YOUR FATHER WAS
THE VICE-PRESIDENT IN CHARGE OF
UKRAINE.
NOW WE KNOW WHY JOE BIDEN THE
QUID PRO QUO WITH HELD A BILLION
DOLLARS TAX DOLLARS UNTIL THEY
FIRED THE PROSECUTOR
INVESTIGATING HIS SON.
I WISH I DIDN'T HAVE TO TALK
ABOUT HUNTER EVER AGAIN.
HIS LIFE AND INVESTMENTS AND
BILL AND LIVING ARRANGEMENTS ARE
SO ENTER TWINED WITH HIS FATHER.
IT'S IMPOSSIBLE TO SEPARATE THE
PAIR.
FOR EXAMPLE, CATHY CHUNG BIDEN'S
EXECUTIVE ASSISTANCE WHEN HE WAS
VICE-PRESIDENT WAS HIRED AFTER A
RECOMMENDATION FROM HUNTER.
EMAILS ON HUNTER'S LAPTOP SHOW
THAT CHUNG COMMUNICATED WITH
HUNTER.
SHE HAS BEEN QUESTIONED BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT AS PART OF THE
INVESTIGATION INTO GARAGE GATE.
HOW COULD JOE BIDEN BE THIS
IRRESPONSIBLE.
THAT'S WHAT HE SAID ABOUT DONALD
TRUMP?
HOW DID THIS HAPPEN?
THIS IS A MASSIVE SCANDAL AND
SOME ON THE LEFT LOOKED SHELL
SHOCKED AND A FEW FLOATED
A THREE THEY THE CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS HAD TO BE PLANTED BY
REPUBLICANS.
MAYBE DONALD TRUMP HIMSELF --
TAKE A LOOK.
>> TO ME, IF YOU ARE MISSINGS
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS IN MY
HOUSE, IF SOMETHING IS MISSING,
I KNOW IT'S MISSING.
>> DOES IT FEEL LIKE THE
REPUBLICANS ARE BEHIND IT?
>> I AM SUSPICIOUS OF THE TIMING
OF IT.
I AM AWARE OF THE FACT THAT
THINGS CAN BE PLANTED ON PEOPLE.
>> Sean: I JUST STUMBLED ON
THESE CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS.
I BET A TRUMP SUPPORTER PUT IT
THERE.
THIS IS INSANE AND PATHETIC.
EVEN DON LEMON AT FAKE NEWS CNN
SEES THE WRITING ON THE WALL.
AND CHUCK SCHUMER WAS NOT HAPPY
BEING ASKED ABOUT IT.
>> I HAVE TO SAY THIS.
YOU SEEM MORE MEASURED ABOUT
THIS THAN WITH THE TRUMP
DOCUMENTS.
YOU CALLED FOR TRANSPARENCY WITH
THE TRUMP DOCUMENTS.
YOU WANT LAWMAKERS TO HAVE
ACCESS TO THE DOCUMENTS SEIZEED
IN FLORIDA.
>> I SAID THAT NIGHT IT'S PRO
MATURE TO COMMENT ON WHAT SHOULD
BE DONE FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THAT'S WHAT I SAID.
>> Sean: NO MORE HYSTERIA FOR
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS FROM CHUCK
SCHUMER BECAUSE THE DEMOCRATS
DIDN'T CARE ABOUT THE CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS.
FOR THEM IT WAS ALL A PLOY TO
GET TRUMP ONE MORE TIME.
THIS IS NOT A GAME.
I THINK MOST AMERICANS SEE WE
HAVE A DUAL SYSTEM OF JUSTICE.
I HAVE VERY LITTLE FAITH IN THE
DOJ THAT THEY WILL HOLD JOE
BIDEN ACCOUNTABLE.
THEY ARE IN HIS EXECUTIVE
BRANCH.
HIS HOME OFFICE HAVE YET TO BE
RAIDED BUT THEY DID THAT WITH
THE DONALD TRUMP.
DONALD TRUMP GAVE THE FBI ACCESS
TO THE ROOM WHERE THE CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS WERE.
THEY WERE IN.
THERE THEY COULD HAVE TAKEN THEM
WITH THEM.
THEY DIDN'T.
THEY SAID PUT A PADLOCK ON THE
DOOR.
THEY COULD HAVE COME BACK ANY
TIME.
BUT THEY DECIDED TO GO FORWARD
WITH A RAID.
THAT MEANS THE HOUSE
INVESTIGATIONS JIM JORDAN AND
COMBER AND OTHERS ARE TAKING ON
A HIGH LEVEL OF NEW IMPORTANCE.
THAT'S NOT THE ONLY CRITICAL
TASK FACING THE NEW MAJORITY.
A DEBT CEILING SHOWDOWN CAN
TAKING CENTER STAGE.
THE GOP BETTER BE READY TO HOLD
THEIR GROUND.
THE SENATOR SCREWED OVER THE
COUNTRY WITH THE 1.7-BILLION
DOLLARS DEAL WITH HUNDREDS OF
DOLLARS FOR GENDER EQUITY AND
THE PRESERVES OF SALMON.
AND HALF A BILLION DOLLARS FOR
BORDER SECURITY IN OTHER
COUNTRIES AND $3 MILLION FOR BE
FRIENDLY HIGHWAYS.
HONEYBEES.
IT'S TIME FOR THE HOUSE TO BRING
OUR BUDGET UNDER CONTROL AND
STOP ROBBING OUR CHILDREN AND
GRANDCHILDREN BLIND.
IT CAN'T COME SOON ENOUGH.
BIG BANKS PREDICT A RESIGNATION.
THE HOUSE MARKET